I just said that using
a combination of push and set value
is the best option for adding new
shopping lists to the Firebase database.
But let me show you why
instead of just telling you.
Right here is where we have
our list of shopping lists.
This is all the data for one list and
here's all the data for another list.
And for the sake of space,
I'm not drawing out the whole tree for
every single shopping list.
Using the three other
methods besides push,
we need to choose what to use as
the key for each of these objects.
A reasonable approach might be to
choose the name of the list as the key.
Consider a scenario where we've
written the code for user accounts.
And in this scenario,
we'll say that both my roommates Walter
and Kagure have their own user accounts.
And we'll say Walter has one list,
which is named grocery list and
Kagure has one list which is named party
supplies, and they're represented here.
Let's decide that at some
point while using the app,
Kagure decides that she wants to make
a list called grocery list for herself.
It's completely separate from Walter's
grocery list that he's made for himself.
At this point, if we're using keys for
names, we'd run into the issue of having
two lists that have the exact same name,
and therefore the exact
same URL location.
So what would happen?
Well, if there aren't any permissions
that are protecting lists from being
overwritten, Kagure's list could
simply overwrite Walter's.
Walter would probably not be
super thrilled to find that
his list has been randomly overwritten.
If we had permissions that kept users
from overwriting other user's data,
then Kagure would be in this
position where she's being
denied to write a list
called Grocery List.
So maybe if Kagure was feeling
particularly like she really
wanted a list called Grocery List, she'd
make something like Grocery List 1.
And the next person could make something
like Grocery List 2, and Grocery List 3,
and so on.
This isn't the best user experience,
and this is kind of silly.
Just because one person has
a shopping list named grocery list,
that doesn't mean that nobody else
using the app should also have a list
called grocery list.
Another option is to not
use list names as keys and
instead to try to find something
else that is certain to be unique.
Enter Push.
Push generates a unique ID for
you to store a list under and
it ensures uniqueness.
Here's some examples of
what push keys look like.
They're sort of bizarre collections
of numbers and letters.
Via Firebase magic, this ordinary string
has the extraordinary attribute of being
completely unique.
So when Kagure wants to add her grocery
list, push will generate a unique
key for her, thus allowing for both
Walter and Kagure to have grocery lists.
Okay so hopefully right now you agree
that using Push is a good choice.
Now Push only generates this key,
so you also need to
use set value to actually generate and
store this value here.
What I want you to do is
update this button so
that it adds a new shopping list
to the Firebase database and
if I keep adding lists I should
see my data growing here.
Now you could watch me do it, but you're
a developer, so why not try it yourself?
I'll send you a spec.
And actually,
in addition to implementing Push,
could you also add
a timestamp created property?
It should store when
the list was created.
It's always good to keep
track of these things.
Before you get started, you probably
want to go ahead and flush the database.
You're making a big enough change
right now that having old data
could create errors or confuse you.
To quote, unquote, flush the database
you can go to the Dashboard and
delete it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's scarily simple,
just click this little red x.
Obviously, in a production app and a lot
of times when you're in development,
this could be really disastrous.
So if you're worried that you might want
to revert back to the dataset that you
had before,
you could always export your data here.
It spits it out as JSON and
then if you ever need the data
back you can import it here.
But this is sort of throwaway data.
>> What?
Where did my shopping list go?
Lila?
>> Got to go but
I'll send over the spec right away.